just hours before the g7 started and the
Iranian Foreign Minister was in Paris
mohammad javad zarif met with president
macro no pictures of the meeting were
released properly so as not to anger
president Trump the meeting behind the
closed doors of the Alizee palace
highlights the very different approaches
of the US and Europe towards Iran
however there is a new face at this
year's g7 UK Prime Minister Boris
Johnson some are speculating with brexit
looming he may want to consider taking a
tougher position on Iran in order to win
favour with Trump if Boris Johnson's
threats of going for no deal really is
true and if what he's been doing in
Berlin in Paris has really just been a
ruse of sorts then you're going to see
the UK pivot towards the u.s. you're
gonna see the UK start agreeing more the
US than his European neighbors and
you're going to start seeing a much more
aggressive level of posturing from Boris
Johnson who will be in the company of
Trump and who will almost be egging him
on to start behaving in a way that's
more US friendly than he you friendly
Iran is just one of an increasing number
of global issues where the seven leaders
are likely to have very difficult
discussions the French president has
already taken the unprecedented step of
deciding not to seek a final communique
at the end of the summit because he
knows there are no words
they'll all be able to sign up to a
number of other countries have been
invited to this year's g7 Prime Minister
Narendra Modi of India will be attending
and the growing tension between his
country and Pakistan over Kashmir is
bound to be discussed growing trade wars
are also leading to fresh rifts the US
and China's difficulties could further
destabilize the global economy and here
in France the new digital services tax
which targets big US tech companies like
Amazon and Google has angered President
Trump who's even threatened to retaliate
with higher tax on French wine ever
since Trump took office the issue of
climate has been one that's caused
divisions at global summits it may well
again be six of the
is one with president mackerel and the
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
leading calls for the thousands of fires
burning in the Amazon to be treated as
an international crisis James Bay's
al-jazeera Peretz